please note that this meeting will be
fully recorded I'll perfectly Tom should
we be required to evacuate the building
would you please leave the room by the
door to the fire escape staircase please
hold both handrails in case the stairs
are wet or slippery if anyone is unable
to use the stairs but they please allow
others to exit the room before they go
to the fire escape door where they can
then be given assistance our simply
point will be in the public car park at
the side of the civic space please do
not delay your evacuation to collect any
but I mean please do not return to the
building until given permission to do
set by council staff apologies for
absence we've received apologies from
council and hook way no apologies of it
receives yet anybody's gone then ok any
non members attending don't think
they're armed the next item 3 is the
minutes of the meeting held on
fourteenth of June which have been
circulated they've already happy to meet
silos has anybody got a question under
some questions earlier anybody funny
question here is about those minutes
okay I'll sign those at the end of
community and straight on to item 5
which is the treasury management annual
review of certain for titanfall received
declarations of interest on there are
none sorry now adding 5 which is
treasury management and nor will you
again this has been so Katie to members
and I believe everyone's had a chance to
sit and perhaps i'll kiss can just
introduce themselves firstly before yeah
metal Thank You chairman terms I'm
mathematical senior accountants so this
is the interaction management report
which is from our section one by one
officer robert manning so i'm here on
his behalf receiving my senses
approaches you can't make it to to
family reasons if I maybe can just
highlight a few things in the report
spring to your attention and first of
all paragraph 1.3 I just want to
highlight their the amount of investment
income that we achieved in the financial
year 2015-16 be in 30 4537 pound slight
slightly under target the revised budget
that was set was forty thousand control
over where you were going to elective
actually gotten over the page and sort
of highlights on paragraph 3.1 in
closing balance as a 31st in March 2016
and the reason why it's 0 as most of you
probably we're doing that the financial
year that this report refers to we
purchased arrow waste vehicles as an
authority top of the process in
purchasing those vehicles was to draw
down on our fixed term investment that
was due to mature in the year that was
used to impart to purchase those
vehicles so all investments as at the
end of the financial year we're on short
term deposit so we didn't have any
long-term investments so that's what and
if you were to look at our balance sheet
our balance sheet and show a zero
balance for that in effect it represents
any long-term investments of which we
didn't have any because we pulled them
basically to pay for the waste vehicles
I just want to update you on paragraph
4.1 since this report has been written
obviously we've gone through European
referendum which has had some
implications on the medium to long-term
bank rate that will be set by the bank
of england I've received correspondence
today from catheter treasury services
who are our treasury advisors that the
bank rate will probably go down to north
point two five percent next month and
they are envisaged that to stay at north
point two five percent until March 2018
it is only a prediction but they come
fairly close in impasse with their
predictions and it seems to be what's
being put in the press as well at the
moment
be mentioned from the governor himself
mark Carnac just to take it to the the
graphs over the page just to kind of put
some perspective on on the dip there in
the first chart so the first jar their
investments outstanding 2050 April 2015
to march 2016 again the deep there that
you see around the summer period the
july-august period of the investments
outstanding that is representative of
when we paid for the waste vehicle so
that's when all their cash basically
went out the door to pay for the
vehicles and then it started to build up
slowly again during the year on the
second chart there the interest rates
again the blue line the average interest
rate line up until that point of where
we purchase their what the waste
vehicles we had a long-term investment
investment up to a year that was
generating north point nine five percent
obviously when we pulled that investment
when it matured we pulled it to pay for
the vehicles everything was short term
and the best rate we were getting short
term was about half a percent through
that that's why that suddenly drops off
there during late August unless there's
any question that's already able to
highlight within maybe work and remember
some clean campaign as crystal frog
thank you cheering and could you tell me
how much the total cost million cause I
can't give any exact figure because it
was in the millions but I've top of my
head but I will confirm this to members
and fire fire told that the top of my
head it was about 2.6 million okay
reminding that then
is nearly and the sea flop in the
interest rate and what is the estimated
interest I'm helping to get from
investments doing this current year the
original budget has been set at 80,000
when when denise marie was our fight one
officer and the budget was set in
February budget was put in for 80,000
but that was based on an assumption that
members would agree to put money into
housing at the time which was paying
back a return of about four percent
subsequent I think we've obviously come
through a review committee with this
year's strategy and there wasn't the
appetite to do that so we will be
revising that budget down and given now
the repercussions through the referendum
and the uncertainty in the market it
will be brought down below well below
eighty thousand i would think we'd be
looking near thirty thousand to support
while the christopher my name's to on
page five point two the second paragraph
in your top where it says or attempting
to choosing environment whispers etc
telovations
from the previous inquiry forgive me if
I'm Robert and we felt it was unwise
just to have the long side one or two
agree that these are punished it should
be done in conjunction with the
portfolio holder for finance I'd have to
check on that and this this report was
agreed by Rob so I'll have to go back
and clarify that he looks young three
thinking cancer stan is it always
necessary to do a long-term investments
when is there are possibilities of any
short-term investments that from no
speak English Lords dark short own and
and not so much capital coming into
though shelters in other words we can
have a portfolio of several small
investments which might give us a better
right yes and we currently don't have
that when I when I talk about long-term
I I'm talking up to a year or anything
six months to a year we classes long
term of the moment within our finances
as it stands at the moment we don't have
anything out past six months within this
financial year everything is we have a
couple of fixed term rate accounts with
santander which we won't be puttin any
further money into but the moment we
have a 30 day notice account with them
and sixty five day notice accounting
that's paying slightly better than you
would get put in the money overnight
saying that we do have an overnight
instant access account with a bang cool
handles banker based in Southend
branch and sell them and we also use
money market funds as well which are
instant access and overnight in terms of
the rates of return on those accounts
money market fund is paying about point
five three percent the handles banking
account is paying point 5 1 percent and
the to sand and their accounts are
paying point 65 and point seven five
percent but again it's likely the budget
if the base rate comes down those rates
will come down unfortunately as well I
just wonder if we could when I say small
account Lloyd's are doing small cans or
inquired wouldn't right at the moment
and I'm I wonder if it would be perhaps
I know it's going to make the portfolio
bigger in the way of the small accounts
but it looks to me that small gases is
going to is a worthwhile inquiry is to
you know to to fund the it'll be better
as they're doing some not three percent
two to three percent I think in terms of
those going to be a ver reach or call we
do them in terms of data that you have
to be careful in terms of day-to-day
banking when you see headlines or
clippings in the paper that say Lloyd's
paid three percent etc it tends to be
for personal accounts rather than an
account that we could drag down money to
I'm just a baby with that Webbie we can
make the only get say 145 or something
like that is to inquire as to whether up
to that so yeah I mean at the moment the
best rate we could get with Lloyds who
are out there the council's make bank we
have our current account will explain
the best rate we could get to them
moment is is not point eight five
percent for 12 months saying that I do
need to draw members attention to the
fact that the country has as a sovereign
country we've been downgraded in the
last week members will be aware that our
strategy that we brought in to this
committee and April recommended that we
only invest with double A+ rated
companies that leads us with a bit of a
problem in the value because this
country has been rated as double I which
is below the Double A plus level robert
manning i won't find one officer myself
had a conference with our relationship
manager capita and he has advised that
we bring a report back into council i'm
not sure if it would come to this
committee or awful full council have to
check that their recommendation is that
we exclude the UK from that process of
looking at only using double A plus
countries their theory behind that is
the government would never allow the UK
banking sector to collapse they would
always support it so their their advice
would be you could go with the double
leg obviously our strategy at the moment
says we can't so as it stands at the
moment I I'm conscious that this is a
backward-looking report and we're going
off the subject of it but as it stands
we are in no new investments with
British banks or building societies at
the moment we're pure using our handles
banking account and our money market
fund but we will be preparing a report
to bring banking government counselor
mr. Mason can I was wat certain level of
a finances that you keep jewelry on
those accounts
yet the strategy allows us to invest a
maximum of six million for six months in
the handles banking account and the
money market fund these three million
for six months thank you thank you the
other questions and a quick question and
on the 1.3 where you talk about income
to investment is there you have you've
already touched on that we first
introduced are important it's not
significantly down and oxygen you
mention further in the ship'll that the
investment isn't a significant part that
incomes the general funds and why was
that lover what's the estimate
unrealistic was there are other
circumstances behind that and I mean I
know it isn't the great deal but yeah I
mean the revised budget was set around
November time 2015 so we still had at
that stage capita who are our treasurer
matter advisors were advising that there
would likely be a base rate rise in
February March time of this year so we
kept the revised estimate forty thousand
assuming that that would happen
obviously it didn't happen now then look
on the other way but that's the main
reason why it was six thousand five five
thousand pounds short of budget
so council mrs. Mason I haven't
indicated mr. chair I'm sorry I thought
you had sorry in third person comes
cancer Stanley another question who rise
disease that with the foreseeable future
that point 05 vice right yeah do you
have something why forward or investment
portfolio as it stands we are tied by
what members have agreed so we brought
into this review committee of our
strategy for this financial year 2016-17
that strategy members took the the
opinion that we wanted to try and remain
as risk free as possible which is
historically where we have been as an
authority so I know the subject around
property funds was broached but that
wasn't taken up so as it stands we are
still using relatively safe and banks
and building societies money market fund
as I say but outside of that we're
limited so most of those accounts are in
line you know they will move in line
with however base rate moves so as you
can see base rate of the moment is half
a percent we're getting just over that
point five one percent in
handles banking account we're saying
that we do have a good local
relationship with those banks and I know
that we're achieving the better rates
and some of our colleagues in other
local authorities within Essex so we
reserve there is an element that you can
tease out of your base rate and the old
point here are there but you know when
you're talking naught point naught 1 set
doesn't do a lot not long enough thank
you any other questions members know at
the end of the report item 8 is a
recommendation and recommendation is to
approve the contents of the review I'm
assuming that your comments earlier you
touched on the revised rates and point
two five that would be amended yes I can
ik ribbon amend that before it goes into
full council so if memory issue mr.
Chairman I don't see that we can improve
in a many report that we haven't seen
however we could propose that we note
this report and there will be an
addendum going into people council but I
don't see how we can possibly recommend
a report that we haven't seen I
certainly doesn't need altering I
realized that the events have overtaken
a report however there is a matter of
accuracy and corrects ages to take the
council
Thank You counselor mrs. makes it so
we'll an addendum the issue yes Mike
later and obviously there is outstanding
issue and the counselor Dre raised with
a gossipy section off certain his
relationship with all fire at home lab
cyclist I will get clarity on that
tomorrow at an email but I become from
port or myself back to all members in
the committee okay thank you very much
um I believe that thank you very much
Thank You members you're welcome to stay
yes I got those here pretty good ok so
moving on to item number six which in
project process and consultation again
I'll stop see or hear in the absence of
yes the one by one of his uncle and
we've all had in consulting so jata
begin yeah it's so so it was suggested
that we broached the subject thus
evening of resident engagement around
the budget process and I pulled some
statistics together to maybe help help
the conversation first year just wood
lice ever met with with robert manning I
151 officer today and his advice is what
his view is he would rather not do it
given the response that we have
obviously that's not his decision as a
member decision but just to put some
stats around where we're at so during
the 2016 17
process which is the five year we're in
now with the budget process starts in
September 2015 there was a budget survey
carried out amongst Botsford residence
we had a response of 344 residents out
of a population of circa 83,000 that rep
that represents a responsive north point
five five percent it was built into the
medium term financial strategy which I
have a copy with me tonight so those of
you who want to have a look it's on page
three point one seven if you still have
that document and and then section 151
officer denise marie put a piece in
there around what we surveyed residents
on and the split of online responses and
hardcopy responses so that that document
the documentation is available if
members wish to see a copy of it it is
also on the council's website so i can
direct people to to that if the diff
needs be found in terms of how we
compared to other sorry in terms of how
we compared to other authorities essex
county council don't do a survey at all
there's there's kind of three top
authorities that are looked at as the
best in the country that do this process
and they're buckinghamshire ken and
gloucester share in terms of of what
responses they got for the same time
scalars as we're looking at and bucking
bashir have a population of just over
five hundred and twenty thousand people
and they receive 2146 responses the same
percentages Arsenal point five five
percent of the population Kent who have
just under one and a half million
population got 2540 responses Norman to
three percent of
ocean and lost this year who have eight
hundred and fifty eight thousand
population got 945 responses nor point
one five percent of the population what
makes those figures even worse liar is
for Buckingham share they spent time and
money on putting an interactive website
and video together for popular for
residents to look at and fill in for
Cannes they did an online questionnaire
street interviews and workshops at their
council building and for Gloucester
share they actually procured a research
firm to put their questionnaire together
and again held a series of workshops so
you can see why the 151 offices response
would be this isn't really worthwhile
given the time and the effort that would
be needed to put in place to put this
questionnaire together saying that it's
not our decision it's remember decisions
no don't if there's any question
counselor mr. Mason Thank You chairman
Matt it depends really at what point of
the cycle or the process you actually
undertake your consultation and we've
always done it beaten before our early
days yes so we're not actually
consulting on anything you have to
asking residents broadly what priority
they would give to certain services and
of course that they haven't found
terribly attractive because they haven't
got much background to be able to make
that sort of comment and then
something's gone wrong and we might hear
if you were to do it put more money to
grass cutting but of course it's always
going to be a knee-jerk reaction what's
out then given on surprise we don't have
anything on south end because South even
started a different and more radical
process they they produce there
budget and he goes to prague castle and
it's around februari time and council
agrees a draft budget and what southend
then do is consult on the draft budget
which does of course i believe certainly
I'm anecdotally believe speaking the
South in residence that it gives them an
opportunity to actually respond to what
the council's doing as opposed to
inviting residents to construct their
own budget now the second case I'd ask
you why if we've taken so much trouble
to produce the ntfs and we have very
clear plans and projects to take forward
in each of the next four years because
one year as Moses become redundant we'll
add another why we don't consult on that
because that should be guiding the
council as to where what is already
determined where broadly in draft wants
to go and it could get the response of
residents to those proposals and you
wouldn't be surprised for me to say
there are at least two very
controversial ones which are in the ntfs
for the next financial year surely the
council wants to consult with residents
and that would be a relevant
consultation to me so i guess i'd asked
why haven't we don't end and i suppose
my next proposal will be to say why
don't we do that okay thank you and
firstly why we haven't done it I don't
have an answer to that unfortunately I I
believe that historically it's something
going whatever if we go back to when
everyone would do it was our section 151
off so we've always done some kind of
resident engagement but it's never
really as you say focused around the MTF
s but it's definitely something that I
can feed back to to Robert and we can
look at for this financial for the 2017
onwards budget process counselor mrs.
Mason Thank You mr. chair I can only
endorse or my old house has said but
also I think the method of communication
has been all we've used Oxford district
matters which is what we all know what
it is and I'm sure it's not very widely
read its realness I don't know we don't
you I don't so have you that is now
going online so that's not going to be
over the method that we have available
torso at the same time as perhaps making
the questions more relevant because they
have been totally irrelevant and I think
they've been the same every year anyone
regardless of the responses perhaps we
can consider a more effective method of
communication perhaps we could engage
the gap parishes and ask them to promote
the questions if the questions have
relevance you will get a response the
lack of relevance is the problem that we
and I don't think how residents I think
our fall by the very general questions
that we've been asking and that's why I
think you get poor response and it is it
not point five five percent mainly
better than the other areas that you're
pointing it's a very poor response to a
marketing strategy with where you would
normally expect on any job to get about
five percent back so we do it we're
doing something oh I don't think you can
blend the residence the council's got to
look at the questions is asking how it's
asking them and perhaps to empower the
residents to give them a feeling of
empowerment perhaps that perhaps the
feeling is that they don't whatever they
respond will not be elected upon perhaps
if you can say if there's a stronger
prompt response we will reconsider that
and it's a budget item then your man to
get some very interesting is out so its
own Thank You mr. chairman thank you i
will fade those back as well thank you
very much cancer stan i will just got
you just said the very words i was just
going to say that they've canceled
amazing then thought if we could get
more information out from two parishes
and and the questions not necessarily
what do you want to see improved on
cancer is probably give them a little
bit of information as to costings and
something like that you know in the wild
but our grass cutting costs us so-and-so
times over do you still want to like
that whatever you know so a little bit
more information not just how do you
feel that the council is he's working
for you or something
those those'll of sentences if you like
would probably help the residency in
putting things in perspective I mean
we've all been in term and said how much
the council he's going to be in debt and
that sort of thing we've seen about a
vice collection all that sort of thing
but don't publicly it doesn't realize
that if they was to actually do certain
things you could reduce the costs of
your and keep your rights though so why
don't we tell them how to do it or not
how to do it but how we goin keep down
all perhaps would you know you've done
this right so perhaps a list of costs of
some of the main construction we have
you the simple so simple anthology the
ones that really involved so that the
rest is for example if I may mr.
chairman buddy the green bin that's been
proposed charge which I'm sure we're all
hala concerned about should that thing
go forward as a proposal you could say
would you prefer to pay slightly more
many more on the rates or whatever so
great stop dating myself but or would
you prefer a one off charge I mean the
residents that I've spoken to it and
then they can just say well we're just
putting the non recyclable so yeah
that's probably that's an issue for
another day but those sort of topical
either or questions once we've got my
draft budget if we go out so these are
the alternatives yep as long as we're
careful to put real alternatives down
and ones that we will listen to I don't
see any heard that the response wouldn't
be a lot higher okay that's fine
cancer hi thank you Jim I know you
commented on caked on them in there are
other areas weeks to do quite a focus
elevators well I think the differential
probably find is the quality of the
survey survey has no quality of
charities very basic it which services
do value which ones you cut essentially
yeah I think you find if you became you
will find that they do there are 20
million to sit down with individuals and
I think that calcium is representative
sample as well so I do a lot more work
so I think that the question is whether
are we really want to take residence
view seriously or not whether we want to
trash you invest in the proper survey or
not a great south end also drink one of
them so Ivan at less cost and I think
it's wise from this came on both whether
you say that Kevin weddings in them
returns Marchese returning quality
information only an old I should call it
sampling are no holes can be wrong as we
learned recently but I'm sure it it
could still be management and all that
obviously kinda quite happy that they're
there something works okay that's what
we need to decide if any more questions
can i grab my great we're going to
survey the residents we've got to have a
meaningful survey they've got to be able
to comment on what we propose that are
not like the idea of them times they or
their company mother I've draft so i
won't particular question do we know how
much the survey Costas i know most of it
leave the biggest one moment is in
watford matters please go home after how
much for instantly dessert was promised
me you would it would only be officer
time and and I I don't have that
information but I can imagine that the
officers involved would have been
someone within finance it wasn't myself
someone within communications I and and
somebody within the print room who puts
the publication together so there would
be in an element of office time involved
there but to put a finger on it I'd be
guessing but if you wants an item for my
sake work it out who says I would think
I would think from the finance side of
things actually put in the survey
together would probably have been one or
two days work and then four columns and
print and design maybe another day thank
you very much any other questions
members
James I thinking from those comments and
feedback thinking it's readable members
are you looking for in- possibly
educator since people have the actual
finances the our own place yep and give
them some more options and okay okay so
item seven the key decisions dr. in
which members have deceived
members will note that from the meeting
had on fourteenth of June that we did
ask Paul to arrange for representatives
committee and discuss these with us so
Paul [ __ ] head over to institute yeah
yep and as a chairman said ever meet not
4 10 2 jun members asked for more
information value our mental health
service plan and asked me to arrange for
officers to attend I've brought along
Martin Hamlet principal environmental
health officer and also and we hadn't
physicist senior mentor to talk about
this one thank you click the opportunity
to and present this year service plan to
you all and this is the first year that
we've had a service wide service plan
ostensibly this is to help promote the
service both amongst yourselves and and
the wider public but members may be a
way that each year members need to
approve the food safety service plan and
that is a particular part that Angela
will stay tuned as you can see in front
of you open the screen we've come
through a graphical representation of
the service just so that it's light
touch and easily accessible rather than
a word document that goes into any
overly descriptive
discussion all the sorts of things that
we do ginseng be left hand side under
services broadly details the types of
work stream that we deal with which all
some of you have already had
representation from and you can see
doing some some of the matters that are
listed of this sorry excuse me so anyway
you can just make it a bit large on a
consciousness care my dear bit bigger
yes so the only one strong in a bit more
hard copy or use it you may guess one of
them think I what we learn with enlarged
eases are going to be and him well I
mean trouble focusing on that thank you
very Jen no problem try there navigate
around the graphic now you've actually
seen him sets as one okay so over here
in services and won't list in a breeder
opening this on the list do you be able
to see there where it's highlighted in
blue you'll be familiar these are
hyperlinks so that the document itself
we once approved is completely the
process we will put this up on to the
website and it will be another way of
navigating around all our services
they're not collected on the internet at
the moment some sits under businesses
section some seats under environmental
as you can see there's quite a broad
spectrum of work types that we had we
have generic pages and then you'll see
as we move over to the right hand side
we have specific projects that we also
chanting remember section here in the
middle performance measures so what we
have there is a single link that goes
through to a page that just really gives
you a player for the volumes as they
occur through the year We certainly have
seasonal trends in our service requests
particularly in terms of noise dust odor
smoke complaints but we will also see
this is there where we get infectious
disease reports the the food safety
inspection says they happen through the
year and the progress we're making
towards the targets that you will
discuss in a moment about some section
on the resources what we are what income
we do handful expenditure doing them in
the center here our headlines so this it
just gives you a flavor of just what we
do with in terms of volume she said we
do with over 1000 service requests in a
year split across all of those subjects
they might be workplace accidents and
might be the top see complained and I've
just detailed early on pollution side it
food poisoning and
foreign objects including those sorts of
things and then we also have our skin
Pierce's our industrial processes which
proved to air which we regulate so again
usually I do how many of what we've got
over here on the right hand side we have
our programs and plans okay one of which
of course is the food inspection program
we have a health and safety inspection
program which is quite limited in nature
it is centered around only a handful of
inspections and then opposite workplace
accident investigations we have a
respective programming for those
permitted activities osteria over air
quality action plan for break high
streets and the town centre generally I
will be back here in the sep tember
meeting to present the progress on that
to become to form a draft Oh quality
action plan for consultation and then we
have a tucking healthy takeaways project
which is about engaging food businesses
privacy aspects of health eating for the
paintings
that's what I want to say about what we
have there obviously when that's out you
will see how that makes through to all
our web pages we have a very strong web
presence you seem to make sense to
utilize that too before so that's the
other dressing for that the meat of the
the plan is so okay thank you martin
we've okay the chair if I stand to one
side so I'm so your screen and look at
the rocket according to you thank you my
name is andrew i'm one of the vern
mental health officers are responsible
for carrying out food hygiene work and
health and safety work and why I'm here
to today is to speak a quick run through
of the food service plan first question
quite have a service plan the reason we
need to have a service plan is a
requirement by the FSA who is the Food
Standards Agency and with a government
body the overseer see ourselves where
Dean is a competent authority so we need
to have a service plan the service plan
sets out what work we need to do within
the year and what work we anticipate
coming in throughout that year it
provides clear targets before the
department that we know what we need to
achieve and we can be measured on and
some prove that we're doing what we need
to be doing and in the correct time
frame right well I've done now is I'm
actually taken out from the service plan
and a table that shows what premises
we're responsible for on the district
the premises are broken down into
categories with a bin into high-risk
category ii being the lowest risk
category a premises i had agreed
something like a butcher's so that's
somebody that produce what potentially
is a high-risk products as in if
something was to go wrong it could go
significantly wrong and generate
previously woods sir there's quite a lot
of customers a category ii premises is
jerry somewhere that sells think the
silver foods such as cans of coke
chocolate bars to a relatively smaller
customer base and therefore
lower risk and less likely to cause a
bigger problem and each of these
parentheses are inspected on a time
frame so as you would expect the
high-risk premises are done more
frequently every six months the lower
extremities are done every three years
and we generally do those both terms of
strategy so we will send them out a
questionnaire rather than send an
officer out the clipboard asking them
questions we will give them a chance to
swab answer and respond back to us in
their own times the high-risk ones we
also do by visit dubai this if you want
to see what it is they're actually doing
and make sure they're doing it correctly
on the premises at the moment we have
631 food premises that we as an
authority are responsible for enforcing
food hygiene on right so the futsal food
practices you have the district of the
food premises whoever districts there
Jerry or quite a high quality quail on a
high standard ninety-four percent of
them have a three or higher on the
national food hygiene rating scheme what
that basically is that's the stick that
it was sometimes see in shop windows at
the 0 to 5 rating 5 being very good 0 in
urgent need for improvement as I say
ninety-four percent of the businesses
and our districts are 3 or above so
we're quite proud of that of the
premises we have in addition we have to
what we will call proof premises or very
high-risk premises these apprentices
that will manufacture a high-risk
product and then sell it to a very large
customer base it nationally or even
across all of Europe we have two
premises that fit that bill one of them
is a butcher's which backpacks meats and
sales across a spoiler different
countries in Europe as well as the rest
of the country and we have shellfish
purification
plans which purifies shellfish which
then go through well cut through any
other further treatment before
potentially there could be eaten all
right this table shows what premises we
have jus for inspection this financial
year so of these six hundred or so that
we have three hundred and two of them a
Jew for inspection as you respect it
takes a pyramid type shape so the
high-risk lines is pure iris ones then
there is the lower risk once right we
also receive a number of service
requests these obviously we can't say
exactly how many they're going to be so
we do it via an explanation so each year
we saw take an average of what we expect
to come in and we're estimated based on
the trend of the last three years we
have roughly 200 service requests these
can range from a number of things just
something is bought product that they're
not happy with the found foreign body in
it or eaten in the belief that make
themselves unwell to businesses actually
coming to us asking us for advice and
guidance on how best for them to comply
with the law and make a product that is
safe for their customers the number of
food-related infectious diseases each
year we be informed of a number of food
poisoning cases where people have gone
to their doctors because they're unwell
the doctors taking a sample and come
back has been a food poisoning case so
these are actually confirmed cases
rather than people just ringing up
saying that I've eaten a certain
restaurant I've been unwell I believe
that that score given me food poison
these are actually confirmed cases right
additional work but we'll have will we
get roughly 150 or so food has warnings
a year a food hazard warning is
basically an
ternational wide alert for a certain if
a certain products be withdrawn so it
could be in products being made at the
found that batch of it has been
contaminated with glass or something
that could make potentially make
somebody unwell so that entire batch has
to be removed so we would be informed as
an authority that its product needs to
be withdrawn from shelves we would then
go to the shops on our district that
would be likely to sell this product and
ensure that they're taken off the sound
so that customers can't buy them another
thing we do quite a lot of eruption is
provide support to our businesses we do
this fire actually use or visits and
coaching sessions so if a business is
having problems complying with
documented procedures that they require
to do we will go out sit down with them
and go through what they need to do we
also hope get involved with promoting
healthy living as part of the
government's wire gender ons or the VCT
and healthier eating weeds will do our
part and get involved in that as well we
do this in a number of different ways so
we're taking part in the National Food
Safety Week where we prove whether that
the theme is for the whole country we
would be involved in that by providing
information and informing the residents
of what you know what breeds we need to
tell them we also involved in the
healthy eating award this generally aims
of schools so they're providing food
that is healthy for the children and
restaurants that have allowing them to
have a choice on the menu so important I
don't just have to have one type of food
they can have healthier option should
they choose and we're also getting
involved in a new project this is an
ethics project called the tuck-in
project now this is a more about
healthier lifestyle so rather than being
just healthy food it's just ways of
making on one plus food menus making the
food
make them happy of your options so
cutting down and salt in certain
products cutting down the fat content
certain products I was going to give you
a very quick review of the previous year
last year we had 322 premises that were
due for inspection Oxford we did 322
premises last year which was over ninety
nine point seven percent the rather
annoyingly we had one premise which was
a homepage which we couldn't get into
which is why we didn't get one hundred
percent total food inspections we have a
planned a number at the beginning of
year as the year goes on you'll get new
premises open up some premises some of
the a great Prince's had done every six
months so they will occur twice in a
year or photos we did 352 instructions
which was ninety-eight percent of the
overall jus for that year last year we
also issued approval for a shellfish
plant which is one I mentioned earlier
as whether to approve premises we also
issued a simple caution which is like a
warning to a business who unfortunately
they cause the case of food poisoning
we're seventeen people suffer from food
poisoning two of which were infinitely
unwell and having required hospital
treatment and thank you all very much
listening if you have any questions I'll
be more than happy to answer them played
counselor Stanley literally I know is
that
you've got the quiet view of the
restaurants all outlets 3mon three out
of five do you go round and inspect so
that you can raise that stand for
anything me although it's good in one
way it's not why I would say an
excellent figure to come out with so
many restaurants that we have him right
here as a whole and that includes the
pubs clubs and what have you is if
they're a program of we currently have
ninety-four percent or mrs. are 3 or
above so actually the rity of them are 5
and force the original use 3 or above is
because the scheme deems 3 as acceptable
but i agree of your point that we don't
want purposes to be a 3 move rather than
to be a four and five so what we do is
if a premise was a three or even below
that we do our best to work with them so
we would sort of first of all say
something you know this is your business
it's better for you to have a higher
score that's what's going to help your
business and it's better that you know
your customers vast majority of business
is once a work of us do work for us we
will arrange visits outside the normal
program to help them coach them to
improve their score we have a very few
the stubborn dig nails in and in those
cases we will then take more formal
action to ensure that they meet the
legal requirements but thankfully
because of the type of districts we are
vast majority of distances do my work
with us to improve their score the
reason I say they use that Repub not so
long ago we did have quite a few
restaurants which will be loads of three
standard and the other question of light
sauce is that do you expect berger veins
and that sort of thing on the amenities
as football grounds and that sort of
thing where they would sell burgers and
anything is come from
all sides you yeah we what we call out
their burger van we would look as a
mobile caterer so we fall into the
scheme they need to be inspected the
wave works is their registered where
they store the wagon overnight so if
it's stored up in our district for your
make arrangements to sort of see them
where it's stored and wherever possible
where they're trading sometimes of
course is that's not possible cuz they
might trade in London or what trade
outside ours or their responsibility in
those cases we would then make that
authority aware that yeah we've got this
business on our district but they tell
us they trade in your part of the world
we also get other councils that we will
find them out about on their inspections
as do we and we will then make if they
say we're interested of Bazell to the
South Bend within contacts that foraa to
make them aware so they can go out and
you suspect them where they're stored as
well as when they're trading so yeah
they get picked up even though there are
mobile page where they do more often the
novel get pics i've also really good
pizza and after them do they get
inspected or other than a you expected
it would depend on their risk rating and
if there was the high risk the RB and i
would be the more frequently they're
done typically something like a burger
van or a mobile food businesses
generally at sea or addy because the
nature of what they're doing i would say
on our district the vast majority fall
into the sea category so that would be
every 18 months but you do nothing that
should be every year if we comment on
them yet but the night across from
whatever yell it remained everybody but
do coming if we had I are really i'm a
franchise that is likely to cause more
problems and the restaurant that he's a
well-known you know
take your point the way this is the
system works is if we was to go to a
certain establishment of mobile caterer
and we was the finder we didn't have
confidence in them because structurally
it was poor weather practices were poor
there is a rating scheme they will go up
and they will get done if it was an a
every six months if is a bit will be
annually it just so happens on our
district we would work with them over a
number of years they want to work with
us we are team 12 of them so that we're
quite lucky the the years of worked with
them they're now into a scene which is
for what they do the lovers think
potentially be loops then Thank you
Thank You counselor mrs. Mason thank you
it useful to ask how much of your work
do you choose and how much you're not
chased it for sure obviously Elijah toys
& 7 I usually say that the vast majority
of your work is defined for you yes did
the for inspections we have to do them
within the national scheme so we will go
out and inspect them as when they're due
when we receive complaints we were every
complaint we receive as well we would
deal with we would sort of see what the
situation is each complaint we dealt so
I definitely depend in what it is that
the vast majority would warrant a visit
or we will go along and have a look and
see walls see what the issue is thank
you but actually I'm cydia below 0i well
yeah I was very sorry but technically
mine is pretty intense yet we are almost
exclusively statutory services yes and
the majority of the work we do we supply
any returns to government departments so
as a Princeton CS with the food hygiene
inspections we report through standards
agency with a health and safety
inspections excellent ports of safety
executive
is the body Department foreign food and
rural affairs it is to them that we
report our environmental permits
inspections and the compliance aren't
there there are things of like the
drinking water Inspectorate private
water supplies and there are here
Deborah also obviously a very hot on air
quality action quality management areas
we report on an annual basis with that
and in fact we have our own status
report will be submitted if not this
week and next it's pretty much
everything that you will see across a
cross day I'm obviously what we do have
certainly with the the nuisance
complaints and those sorts of things we
have a duty to investigate but of course
there are priorities within that based
on urgency what a series as well as
other issues in forming our world we can
attend and also staffing levels at
weekends I'm sure has an impact but has
except having said that but using a very
very little in the room to remember to
introduce charges and you've been quite
proactive I've seen introducing one here
so so yeah that's to be commended that
the field of wood knight sabers to tell
me if I may I found both presentations
very informative and very helpful and we
were done side like this anything good
you don't thank you
you got a list of risk categories could
you give me some idea what was on
premises are involved in each of those
categories yeah of course is a brief one
dev course a category a would tend to be
some Urlacher butchers somewhere who's
producing for what we call high-risk
food a category B the camera systems
worked out on what they do how they're
doing it the actual proof of actual
business then there's an element of
haledon are they doing it as well as
they can be expected to certain premises
no matter how clean and how tidy and how
good they are would always be an a or a
bit because they're doing a high-risk
product so an a would be a butcher's
someone like that be would tend to be a
restaurant that's doing cooking in a
high-risk way so there is sort of
systems of cooking like sous-vide which
like a glorified boil-in-the-bag where
they cook a lower temperature for a
longer time which has more chance to go
wrong so that we that sort of premises
probably be a restaurant that does the
heston blumenthal style cooking would be
a beam or premise such as a normal
standard restaurant but has poor hygiene
standards poor management standards so
we need to go back more often to check
on them the sea is dominantly your
takeaways that you would see on the high
street and restaurants game because the
nature of what they do they're going to
fall into that sort category B SC or
addy sow the seeds of the DS are mostly
sort of the restaurants depend on how
compliant they are and the categories
are generally like yer off-licences
corner shops places that won't do any
sort of cooking will just be selling
silvered Mars bars cans of coke and home
caterers that might do make cupcakes
things like that Thank You Katie
look it even got to mention just just to
follow up and when the right things are
quite fluid and as Andrew said about the
compliance he's part of the factor as
well as just inherent nature of what
their business is so a particular firm
having been a certain category letter it
might be an A and B jeepers inspection
twice but it can be obviously perfect is
just because the nature of what it does
that gives you that what imperious to be
an inflated categorization what runs
alongside that is the food hygiene
rating school which is the zero to five
that was discussed earlier that's the
green sticker you've seen your door
beyond on the moving through premises
you might go to that is it is another
better education of compliance for me
and so those schemes run alongside one
another if you were to put a letter and
the number together wouldn't necessarily
make that connection about compliance
and you know how could it is so few
years ago and have my business in
rockford had a a check coming from a
certain Indian restaurant several times
asking for poison for cockroaches which
it didn't sell at the time did report it
to you and you close them there yeah I
know the premise you're referring to
that was myself look
yeah I think obviously building this
doesn't come under you does it health
and sanity buildings and in Jimmy's in
terms of dangerous truck yes there's a
ya booty control function although we
have a system yeah but building control
will deal with construction them so if
it was falling apart they would do
ordain structure the actual goings on
inside the building like the actual work
activity for motives for some buildings
forced to us it's split between
ourselves and health and safety
executive depending on what the work
activity is ok so could have been
building houses is not in under your
remit no great houses have been built
dangerously incorrect practice that he
taken place because your construction is
one of the things that folks for Health
and Safety Executive so they would have
a postman at every now over that Thank
You councillor Stanley thank you Germany
took two points a lot to bring up one is
when you do deliver your air quality
when you show last year's figures or you
know a succession of figures leading up
to the new years yet we've that being
you'll the Timothy the annual status
report that led to earlier you say it's
backward-looking approach me to say and
we publish it it's the first iteration
if you like
this particular report but you will look
at the calendar year 2015 so yes we do
have that we submit that step or for
approval distance that but we will
finish straight away onto our web pages
so we have some air own according to
pages but we also put it up on to se te
org which is funded or essex local
authorities pulling together to give
information data to to the public and
industry you see all you do is only
industry the other question is with the
phone hi Jane I know we've had problems
recently anything when I say recently in
perhaps couple years of companies do you
go back to visit their property or
properties and perhaps more regularly
than what you would do not give it six
months as a restaurant yeah where you've
had a problem would you go back before
that year is up and do so to inspections
a year some of it well what we do
through an inspection we find these
things are inputted right we will give
them a time frame to put them right then
we do what we revisit where we will go
back to make sure they've done it rather
than white women s especially becomes
you and then if they've had problems it
affects their scoring one of the
criteria dents in management so they
would like to get their next inspection
a bit sooner anyway just to make sure
that they haven't just put it right
because we've stood on the shoulder it's
something there now ingrained into their
day-to-day routine and doing it all the
time so it's thing you can think and
I've got a couple of questions will sell
for 400 new business starts can it
actually stop trading before you inspect
it food business yes are you yeah and
the law requires a new food business to
register with ourselves 28 days before
opening
however we take a relaxed approach on
that so if a business was to phone me up
and say that I want to start trading
tomorrow depending on what it is if less
of something particularly high risk we
would allow them to do it but if it was
evenly was something particularly high
risk would make every effort to be there
so they could open up and train as soon
as possible but yeah well essentially we
allow them to but technically they need
to register with us 28 days beforehand
that the official government is to get
small businesses up and running as quick
as possible so we work with them and I
have a bit of a relaxed approach on it
so what very long have for the residents
allowable to say not to fight bullying
oh no they're not allowed to show it
seldom inspected the the scheme does
have a waiting inspection sticker so if
it was a new business and this is we can
send them as thicknesses that they're
awaiting inspection so the customers
know they're not the fact they not
displaying the stories in fact because
I've got a bad score to the fact that
they're new and they haven't got one yet
but yeah we make every effort to get out
soon as possible for the new businesses
so they can get trading and get this
floor as quickly as possible thank you
again augment that the the displaying of
that gorilla sticker for the food
hygiene rating scheme we know it's not
mandatory almost I mean lots of the
moment at the moment it's a mandatory
house and they're using Wales as a test
and then the intention is to eventually
make it national we haven't been given a
date when that would be yet but yet as
you stand the moment in England it's not
a legal requirement to display the
schools they displayed on the website so
anybody you can go online and have a
look for that premise what its core is
but they don't have to actually have on
the door at the moment
thank you go cats dragon if I can start
up a person making huger critical point
is I like putting on a green sticker
crucial as long as he's got a number the
premises is acceptable or is you got to
have a four or five the the scheme says
anything it says three is acceptable so
three above the scheme says its
standards anything below the three is
generally means that they need some sort
of improvement works to be carried out
now in even if they'd asked all alone of
three it doesn't mean that if you go in
there you're likely to be poisoned or
become unwell and we find a premise
that's in that state we will close them
to stop and trading so they wouldn't
poison or make anybody unwell it just
gives you an indication of just how
clean tidy they are just how well from a
food hygiene point of view they're
running their business they're under
through then they witness we have to
show you do they really just like that
that's the thing you generally find
people with a score of love and 3 4 110
knots display ok and come back home to
inspections can you do unannounced
inspections presumably of some sort of
tip off if you have derived two clubs
infirmities and spraying rifles and we
and we have the de brighter such to do
all of our food inspections unannounced
and we do all of our food inspections
I'm announcing except for visits to home
page routes it's obviously it's a
domestic setting we wouldn't want to
just turn up at somebody's house
unannounced and the government grants is
we should give them 24 hours notice
anyway but we do all our home specials
by appointment any then it's like
anything to shop on the high street we
will turn up on and out so they don't
know we're coming obviously we apply an
element of common sense if we go in and
we see it their busiest point and
there's all customers in an eventual
swamp to deal with customers we would
then make a decision if it was a
business we have confidence in we will
go away and come back another
unannounced time if it's a premise that
we was unsure about them Jim standing
the background of watch what they do
because that's the time you likely to
make your mistakes but where possible we
work with them unannounced one final
question alleviate Quality Survey me
once you finish that survey and for
instance you find that the air quality
is not up to scratch what sanctions have
you got to try and alleviate doing
approve the air quality
right took at you I haven't put it up
number of air quality reporting in past
years in particular in the build-up to
actually declaring the air quality
management error in rightly and one we
previously had over of raw flame which
which covered the housing estate
adjacent to north industrial estate and
there are no sanctions on others that we
have is not a the legislation that we
use the environment act is not one which
gives us at any additional power at all
it is one which gives us duties to
monitor for certain pollutants and then
to where we find that we failing to
achieve what's called an objective
target level but then we must take
action by first declaring an Air Quality
Management Area and then devising an
action plan to even take those
incremental steps to achieving
compliance what I can't it will
obviously group are linked from our
service plan takes us taking three to
our web pages which does go through that
side they've reporting monitoring in
depth but I can make sure it is a point
the briefing that comes to this
committee is that tempo cos will be
obviously talking about thee the whole
process as well as the action plan to
and then so I really didn't answer the
second part of relationships I've
enclosures the premises or whether we
can do them immediately and closures
thankfully are quite rare and we would
only close the premises there was
significant issues and problems but if
we find purpose in that state we do
close them immediately we then have to
go to Magistrates Court where to apply
to match transport within three days to
go through the magistrates to justify
why we've done it and to make sure we've
complied with the law and the
regulations that rest upon us but
thankfully in Russia district Bay is
quite rare except for the Opera approach
but thankfully they are quite rare I
much got a couple of quick questions
hopefully and then if we can bring this
awesome 22 ahead and when a service
request think what you first that is
made are there protocols and procedures
that are actually set in place that you
have to follow and are they set by
yourselves IDC or they set by some
national body that you follow and are
those guidelines that you're following
on protocols are they public if I was to
break a service request would I be
easily able to access information about
what I should be able to expect
following my service request ok so the
entry procedures for new route through
investigation service standards if you
learn your elders
in terms of a nuisance ID which comes
the bulk of complaints if you went to a
service requests we have internal
procedures internally generated so they
are rotted district castle badged and
they fairly well established but they're
not created in isolation so they are
peer-reviewed they're taken from Brest
practice amongst neighboring authorities
as well as nationally including the
training officers get that augments that
over time a lot of what those procedures
contain is how we collect information
both directly the point of that service
regress being made but then from the
requester of the service if you like at
that time in terms of but they are sort
of food and in terms of density of food
law code of practice which is quite
details when we should do a complaint to
how we should deal with it all sort of
things we should deal with which will be
incorporated into what we had a call our
standard operating procedures so what we
should do when we receive a service
request or complain for health and
safety there is again similar guidance
called the local authority circulars
which stipulates what sort of things we
should do how should investigate for
accidents it's very prescriptive there's
a [ __ ] boss list of what kind of injury
the person's had and how they've been
injured and where they left the scene
went to hospital as to whether or not we
were then investigated so there is
detail criteria which obviously is free
if remember the public requested to say
we will obviously make that available to
the
to society on the rest of it out the web
content and the leaflets that we produce
duty tell what a procedure is so it
gives you an idea of the information we
require from someone but also what our
service is what our method of
Investigation is going forward that's
then the Quentin to the point that we
correspond with that that personal those
most people who are using a service so
not does go into detail on the raw side
but it was that the indicate of what
what we will do what information we need
to pursue that investigated the other
question I have really was the
description of this plan if it's the
word objective it says it outlines the
objective which to me suggests that this
plan will be advising the reader of what
we as a as a council are planning to do
the aspirations of future yes thing what
we've seen tonight is very informative
very interesting it's very much based on
statistics in in this plan is it is
there are they clear objective what are
the objectives are you aiming to
increase the ninety-four percent to X
percent are you aiming to bring down the
number of complaints or service requests
to a particular level are there are
there clear objectives that these are
the objectives are and the plan shown to
either yes their spirit statistics led
the
really that's based upon what we the way
that we are monitored and the way that
we report our programs and clearly the
plans and that we have over here say
what we expect to achieve in terms of
the inspection programs of which there
are three there as well as the two sort
of project-based plants that we have one
around their quality and the other one
the tucking side so it's a bit of both
to answer your question everybody it's
very statistically it is about meeting
the targets that we are set nationally
and then report upon ok but just decide
to pick up on your comment about the
ninety-four percent do we aim to improve
that that is it's not a statute
requirement on us as an authority to
prove that based very much something we
aim to do previous year it was
ninety-two percent so we've increased it
for 92 294 also when you get into the
high percentage it's difficult to get
any income is ax is that information
included in that you know to increase
that I mean 92% is a high percent anyway
so to increase in size at all although
it's only two percent to me that's a big
achievement is that including the plant
to show people exactly that the food
service patient prescription we it was
set what we need to report on by the FSA
okay so it's not actually something
that's in the plan as such but it is
something we definitely strive to do but
it I take your point i'll try and work
something in there to that effect show
that's something that we want to do and
we'll all that vain for sure what you're
alluding to is certainly a
line officers and we certainly see the
value in things like responding to
licensing consultations and planning
consultations to try and head off the
potential adverse effects that would
result in service with lesbian motor us
after the event we certainly act
proactively in those sorts of ways but
yet they're not detailing quite away
okay maybe UT okay thank you very much
last question if it's a quick one thing
Germany's really equipment in as much as
do we carry the leaflets that you're
talking about in our entrance lobby
booking if you do that's great and
anyone's doesn't know is that there's a
293 due to fees for inspecting is that
this year next year or the year after
all how many people have you got to
inspect and if it's only by these got
years working front of him yeah it's a
place of balance of different categories
that is usually inspected so yeah is
balance of different parentheses
definition and as Felicia it's actually
the figures now increased because we get
new pregnancies all the time so I think
it's 302 from memory in one of the video
yeah and it changes as well so because
our two three new branches open tomorrow
to figure I'll go up we might have some
clothes and the finger goes down some of
them liable might be rated was a super
lingo for legs a little damage you again
forms that way so it's a very fluid
figure but yet it's quite a large bottle
of Gandia because on top of that we've
also got the complaints and the
accidents and everything else that feeds
into it it keeps us busy officers
lovely thank you very much he was healed
of that area Tim quite widely so thank
you for your time gentlemen thank you
very much for listening to this
appreciate thank you pleasure thank you
for this ask how you'd like to surf like
that I think it feel very help remembers
happy possible is it ready in holding
adamant you mean yet or presentation
I'll destroy the presentation yeah I
could arrange for that to be circulated
if that's so I think it's got anything
else okay i'll get so much for thank you
very much thank you
thank you under game
ok
presentations are very good very good
very important to me everybody see okay
or Jordan lights go on moral support and
you want to share with your advisor okay
i tole painted eyes when I've even is
the work this has been circulated all so
has everybody seen a copy of it or
gotten off of it you got some spares you
need them got a spare one and you can
share the job opportunities fun with the
meeting and then I'm just take your
knees I'm going to hand over to Paul
watching for this one remember don't one
okay take the June meeting and there is
items were picked on we've granted
Community Safety Partnership and request
was to the police come to that one as
well they actually agreed and all look
denims over the sixth of sep tember air
quality management areas was mentioned
who knows that's also booked in for the
sixth of sep tember and Martin will be
coming back for that one to go in to
complete our life on that October foot
down the homelessness and the council
housing strategy and disable certain
grants and that would be the reason most
and then on the eighth of November and a
su hardy the chief executive from South
in university hospital NHS Foundation
Trust has agreed to come to talk to the
committee and I will be asking for areas
you wanted to cover later on beforehand
okay and think that's the bare all
it was a
request about highways three speed
limits I've contacted counselor right
house and he has agreed to come here got
his diary at the moment but soon as he's
got it i'll be out for a date with him
and he's asked me if i can just provide
questions for him so he knows what he's
got to cover when he comes all right
apart from there yet there was a couple
of additional items yet these are
additional items that were were raised
by members and we briefly touched on
that last meeting I understand that they
were bought for them because it is a
request of counselor mr. Mason I think
but all of them are just the tip which
was the suitability relevance of the
Constitution and the train and services
next I'll cancer mr. Bryson apologize
changes in the council's work in
practice it's nothing anything that's
just the one no I just if it wasn't me I
don't say that we shouldn't be
implemented this we should be
no so am I asking was it just the one
that you suggested which was Jean
suitability relevance of the
Constitution well I wasn't updating yes
i have but i was told
anybody I didn't did anybody else but H
changes in the council's which is lit
they're off on there for a long time and
with regards the Constitution think
people could have some questions about
that one whether it was in the entire
constitutional where there were
particular areas or sections on
Constitution that you particularly
wanted to have reviewed captain's
license and I don't think too that on
and members may not know that the whole
Constitution is on the assistant
director legal departments
responsibility to renew the whole
Constitution the last time it was
reviewed was a long time ago but what I
can tell he was there was very little if
any input from members at all and it
ended up in front of full council we
more or less if I to complete in the way
it was put together only matters of
grave importance could be raised at the
time given that we're now looking or our
assistant director Lee was looking at
the whole Constitution then we have the
opportunity in this committee to provide
that member input along the way of that
review I'd like to see it being all
groups represented on it but that of
course is a decision of the committee
any comments he wasn't
money cool it was that that does seem
like a quite substantial task my it's
there a competitor yep shorter and the
assistant that whole legal services will
not be doing this except on a objective
basis my recommendation to this
committee if it was so interested in
taking this on in the task group would
be to ask the assistant director legal
to present to the task room how she's
tacking it and that being so we can have
input into areas that may may not have
been covered by that that caused cause
problems cause issues or we may want to
say that we can be happy with certain
sections and maybe she mean look at them
in detail this is a this is a review
that's being undertaken professionally
it's not one for Arsenal society to
drive but we can have been put into it
as we go thank you this is generally I
think what we can't understate is how
important the Constitution is
everything we do every action will take
is governed by that document and I'm
hoping that counsels of reading it's not
an easy document to raid it's not an
easy document to understand but it could
be made more full of user-friendly and
it could be how important their from
members to Frank that and this is an
opportunity that we have I don't think
we should let go by yeah I could I would
hope I think casas hope this expect them
to realize the importance of it I think
it was just trying to from from the
information we have the outset was just
trying to really understand exactly what
we were going to focus on what the
working on would focus on all the coins
no I see where you coming from on that
and I'm quite happy that's not an issue
and to move it forward you need to up
for volunteers for your project tail and
then I'll don't miss it at that point
chair and I may even would like to
repeat it I'd expect this to have at
least every group on the council
represented otherwise when it comes
before full council it won't have the
sort of some sort of very verification
and validation that it really needs
so members we've all heard so sorry I
can say that the project that counselor
mr. Mason worked on with my late wife
you had a lot of problems because of the
Constitution as it was written and I do
agree that it does need updating and
okay so i think we didn't need to look
look very closely okay so members are
happy with the additional item being
looked into by working group and i hope
you to act on counselor mr. Mason's
recommendation that it's a cross-party
group that are formed do we have
volunteers of the review committee that
would light step forward and be involved
in that process I'll be involved thanks
for Lucas go counseling man's amazing
I'll be involved event chairman mr.
chairman sort of here is I've always do
every record you fill them I'm happy to
be on a committee but obviously we need
to be the evenings because the work
commitments or so yeah hasn't been up to
the committee to determine
our evenings convenient so I ran three
miles upon have we got members from the
other groups you got a news yeah yeah
listen cancer Stanley like you happy to
do it fun I just need representatives
from census from regionality so be true
you have each yes sir Stanley I'm total
cs6 counselors I'll just rewrite this is
that right so you know what yes
including did you say you I'm quite
happy to yes we need something whichever
the thing we need to take that
responsibility to see in action see it
seemed be done the name that goes for
all of us I think you know that's
something we need to do okay
ok so I'll fix it informed so will you I
will take it on from there and I'll
speak to extra ok is everyone happy with
that yep ok ok thank you very much
chairman would you want the or when you
on the information for each other agents
that you want but it's not always comply
everywhere you have that I'll come out
to you buying power back tonight there's
any other questions on it anything
anything else to discuss we closed the
looting at Tunis half mine thank you all
for coming